es un proceso de conteo de votos muy
lentos de 90 sillas que tiene la
asamblea de irlanda del norte se han
declarado hasta el momento 15 10 de
estas son para el sinn fein lo que nos
muestra que este partido republicano
está creciendo en el porcentaje de
nuevos votos y como lo mencionaba las
proyecciones indican que el sinn fein
será el partido que más votos tendrá
será el más votado y si esto sucede será
histórico porque en 100 años de
existencia de esta región británica
habrá por primera vez un gobierno
republicano esta región desde su
creación ha sido unionista es decir
quiere estar dentro del reino unido- si
se proyecta a ese gran triunfo arrasador
del sinn fein entonces empiezan a surgir
preguntas sobre el futuro del reino
unido- como unión dado que el sinn fein
en el futuro podría buscar un referendo
para la reunificación de la isla de
irlanda e independizarse del reino
unido- esa por el momento no es una
prioridad de este partido pero ha sido
de sus promesas históricas